It often takes a whole bunch of creative minds
to make a movie happen, and they don't always
have a unified vision.
The director and screenwriter might disagree
over how the story should go, or studio execs
might make changes after test audiences decide
that seeing the Titanic sink is just too sad.
Were these movies improved by the changes
they went through on their way to the big
screen?
Fortunately, their original endings have survived,
so we can judge for ourselves.
Terminator 2: Judgment Day
It's now a massive franchise spanning half
a dozen films and a TV series.
But director James Cameron wrapped up the
story he wanted to tell with Terminator 2.
Or at least he tried to.
The film initially ended with an epilogue
set 30 years in the future.
Sarah Connor tells the audience that the "Judgment
Day" of August 29, 1997 came and went without
any sign of a robot-human war.
John Connor is a senator and a dad.
"The luxury of hope was given to me by the
Terminator."
It offered a satisfying conclusion after the
frightening emotional rollercoaster of the
first two films.
But studio bosses didn't like the epilogue
because it meant no more time travel, no more
robots…and no more sequels.
"I'll be back."
Titanic
"I'll never let go.
I promise."
Another James Cameron movie, Titanic concludes
on a sweet, romantic note: Old Rose throws
the Heart of the Ocean overboard while on
a boat full of explorers actively looking
for that very gem.
Then she goes to sleep and dies and is reunited
with Jack, the great love of her life.
It's probably a better ending than the first
one Cameron wrote.
Old Rose is caught by the crew throwing the
Heart of the Ocean into the sea.
The explorers go nuts.
And then Bill Paxton laughs like a fool.
The Butterfly Effect
The good news: Ashton Kutcher can time travel.
The bad news: His constant manipulation of
time, as well as his general existence, messes
up the lives of everyone around him.
So, at the end of The Butterfly Effect, to
spare his one true love the pain he caused
her, he goes back in time and makes sure they
never meet.
But the film initially called for the character
to go much, much, much farther back in time
to prevent the damage he caused.
Like, all the way back.
He goes back to his own gestating body and
strangles himself with the umbilical cord.
Gross.
The Blair Witch Project
This found footage horror flick ends with
Heather finding her film school buddy stuck
in the corner of a derelict basement facing
the wall, just before she gets knocked out
by some unseen menace.
This lives up to the Blair Witch murder motif
they learned from the locals earlier.
The original ending is more to the point,
with Heather finding Mike's hanging body instead.
Clerks
Kevin Smith's directorial debut depicted a
day in the life—with a few side adventures—of
a convenience store clerk.
His original ending finished the film on a
dark note that's also a sadly unavoidable
occupational hazard for anyone standing behind
a retail counter:
"Oh, I'm sorry.
We're closed."
Dante is shot and killed in a robbery.
Just think: if he'd kept that ending, we never
would've gotten to see the cinematic masterpiece
that was Clerks II.
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which
movie you think would’ve been better with
its other ending.